[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va aujourd'hui alors regardez
ce qu'on va parler on va parler
automobile on est sous le soleil du
Portugal on n'est pas encore au mois
d'avril on est au mois de mars c'est
agréable et c'est Audi qui nous a invité
aujourd'hui pour venir découvrir la
nouvelle Audi Q8 i Tron on a plein de
modèles c'est bien évidemment du 100%
électrique ce sont des modèles 55 vous
allez tout savoir je vais vous expliquer
on va regarder quelle est cette nouvelle
voiture qu'est-ce qu'elle peut apporter
l'intérêt oui non il y a pas mal de
nouvelles technologies moi j'ai la
technologie et c'est justement ce qu'on
va venir regarder aujourd'hui les
nouvelles technos embarquées de cette
Audi Q8 i Tron on va également parler
sensation de route on va également
parler et bien recharge beaucoup plus
performante on va également parler
puissance bref on va se marrer sur les
routes du Portugal alors vous êtes prêts
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
nouvelle Audi Q8 c'est juste un monstre
le plus haut de gamme en électrique
aujourd'hui chez Audi alors en quelques
chiffres c'est 300 kilowatts de
motorisation 400 8 chevaux une autonomie
de 532 km sur le modèle SUV c'est celui
qu'on a juste ici mais on peut monter
jusqu'à 552 km sur le modèle Sportback
et tout ça avec une batterie de 114 kg
mais ce qui m'intéresse ici c'est que
c'est un véhicule qu'on peut venir
recharger beaucoup plus vite que les
autres on va jusqu'à 170 kW c'est assez
dingue ça vous permet de la recharger à
80% seulement 31 minutes alors on peut
également le recharger en 11 kW vous
mettrez 11h30 à peu près enfin bref une
bonne nuit bien tranquille bien tassé à
la maison en 22 kilowatts à 6h et ça
c'est très cool
on se parle ici d'une voiture qui est
hyper tech avec pas moins de 6 écrans à
l'intérieur alors j'ai tout vous dire
que sont ces 6 écrans à quoi ils servent
ou est-ce qu'ils sont positionnés
comment on les utilise 6 écrans vous me
direz c'est pas banal certes mais ces
écrans qui ont vraiment leur sens mais
avant de vous montrer ces 6 écrans et
bien on va refaire un tour du point de
vue de l'extérieur parce que Audi est
venu retravailler améliorer optimiser le
design de sa Q8 première chose qui a été
améliorée c'est la partie avant avec un
design qui a été revu à l'avant alors ça
peut paraître très léger mais il y a
quand même eu quelques petites
améliorations ici alors attention
effectivement il y a des améliorations
il y a une différence également une fois
de plus entre le modèle SUV qu'on a ici
et le modèle Sportback qui sera plus
agressif que je vais préférer mais c'est
pas le modèle qu'on a nous ici
aujourd'hui il y a également un travail
d'amélioration qui a été fait sur les
côtés de la voiture alors là je vous
gâche pas qu'on a roulé dans les chemins
on a mis de partout avec plein de
poussière mais il y a un travail qui a
été fait ici vous allez retrouver le
modèle du véhicule c'est à dire que si
je l'ai enlevé un peu la poussière vous
pouvez voir Audi marque Q8 i Tron
quattro vous allez retrouver d'un côté
mais également de l'autre bon
normalement il y a pas de poussière donc
vous pouvez le voir facilement mais
également un design qui a été
retravaillé à l'arrière du véhicule mais
l'agent convient c'est pas très évident
de s'en rendre compte parce que une fois
de plus on a fait les dingues on a mis
de la boue et de la poussière partout
mais allez la voir en concession parce
que franchement elle est hyper chouette
et comme c'est une voiture taille je
vous l'ai dit vous avez pas moins de 6
écrans et là vous êtes déjà en train de
regarder le premier écran le premier
écran c'est quoi c'est l'affichage du
rétroviseur parce que s'il y a plus de
rétroviseur miroir c'est un écran
tactile en plus qui vous permet de voir
exactement ce qui se passe à l'extérieur
de votre véhicule faites à l'extérieur
ou d'avoir un rétroviseur vous avez une
caméra qui vient situer là c'est pas une
grosse nouveauté mais en tout cas c'est
intéressant et pour moi c'est une
découverte parce que je l'avais encore
jamais utilisé sur un véhicule vous avez
donc un écran sur le côté où vous allez
pouvoir voir votre rétroviseur alors la
côté gauche on a exactement le même du
côté droit et en plus ce qui est
intéressant ici c'est que cet écran est
tactile vous voyez donc ce qui est
affiché par votre caméra sur votre
rétroviseur et si je viens appuyer
dessus et bien voyez je peux venir
déplacer pas ma caméra mais me déplacer
dans l'image parce qu'en fait ma caméra
elle va filmer un an qui sera un peu
plus grand que ce qui va venir
s'afficher ici donc je me déplace dans
l'image très facilement alors j'ai pas
autant de degrés de liberté que avec un
rétroviseur que je pourrais venir
déplacer soit manuellement soit
électriquement mais néanmoins je peux le
faire et une fois que j'ai un angle un
peu pourri vous voyez je suis sur reset
et ça me repositionne ma caméra de façon
un peu normale un peu standard et si je
me switcher sur l'autre rétroviseur
comme je suis conducteur et bien voyez
j'ai qu'à appuyé ici j'appuie sur la
petite icône ici et je suis sur le
Rétroviseur passager que je peux venir
de la même manière moduler très
facilement et voyez là je suis en train
de moduler on voit absolument rien qui
bouge si vous voyez l'écran de l'autre
côté bien vous voyez je suis côté gauche
mon doigt et ça bouge sur l'écran côté
droit comme ça je me rends compte en
direct ce qui se passe de l'autre côté
sur l'affichage rétroviseur côté droit
et une fois de plus je peux venir le
mettre sur un angle un peu pourri
j'appuie sur i7 et ça me repositionne en
position un peu plus classique
[Musique]
en fait ce qu'a fait Audi et ce qui est
assez malin au niveau des rétroviseurs
c'est en mettant ces petits rétroviseurs
caméras ils viennent vraiment gagner en
aérodynamisme et la marque m'a dit
qu'ils arrivaient à gagner 7 km
d'autonomie c'est quand même
relativement énorme juste en changeant
cette typologie de rétroviseur vous avez
donc votre écran rétroviseur avec trois
couleurs vous allez avoir du vert du
jaune orangé et du rouge on va
comprendre que c'est une gradation qui
va vous informer de passage de véhicule
pour votre angle mort donc quand c'est
rouge c'est très très prêt attention
quand c'est vers ça arrive plus ça va se
rapprocher et plus la couleur va les
tendre vers le rouge si vous faites
doubler par exemple vous voyez c'est
jaune ok vous êtes averti d'ailleurs il
faut savoir qu'ici cette Audi Q8 Itron
c'est le premier
Q8 électrique de la marque alors il y
avait d'autres Q8 qui existaient bien
évidemment mais on parle de thermique ça
c'est le tout premier Q8 électrique donc
un élargissement de la gamme parce
qu'aujourd'hui pas mal de modèles
électrifiés en nitrone il va y en avoir
de plus en plus dans les années à venir
et notamment un Q6 e-tron qui va arriver
à la fin de l'année donc fin 2023 vous
allez avoir un nouveau modèle c'est le
Q6 i Tron qui aujourd'hui n'existe pas
[Musique]
donc là on est déjà à deux écrans sur 6
il nous en reste encore quatre à venir
découvrir donc vous vous en douterez
vous avez quand même différents écrans
ici pour venir assister à la conduite et
avoir aussi le côté plus multimédia et
pas réellement un tartinement mais un
tout petit peu derrière le volant vous
avez l'Audi virtual cockpit c'est un
écran un grand écran vous en douterez
vous connaîtrez il y a rien de bien
nouveau ici c'est un écran de 12,3
pouces et du TFT qui va venir afficher
toutes les informations dont vous avez
besoin c'est-à-dire l'autonomie la
vitesse le GPS vous pouvez me dire
changer les vues directement sur le
volant grâce à un petit bouton Tout ça
pour avoir accès aux informations
essentielles directement sans être
dérangé juste sur la droite entre le
conducteur et le passager avant vous
allez avoir deux autres écrans un écran
de 10,1 pouces de diagonale sur le haut
et un écran de 8,6 pouces sur le bas
l'écran du haut vous servira pour pas
mal de choses vous avez donc tout votre
système d'exploitation aussi c'est mimi
touche respond de Audi vous allez
pouvoir effectivement venir naviguer
alors on a vraiment une sensation de
toucher à petit ici média radio
téléphone navigation il y a absolument
rien de nouveau ici si vous connaissez
l'univers Audi bien vous retrouvez très
facilement vos repères vous avez bien
évidemment la Radio Ici vous avez votre
musique ici c'est mon iPhone à
l'intérieur vos appels téléphoniques
votre GPS bref tout est ici c'est simple
c'est bien fait c'est pas je trouve
l'expérience la plus intuitive mais j'ai
commencé à m'y habituer donc globalement
ici je suis quand même moins choqué
qu'au début où j'ai découvert cette
expérience la discussion l'écran du bas
vous allez venir afficher les
informations utiles notamment envoyer
ici la climatisation les sièges
chauffants la ventilation recyclage de
l'air intérieur bref il y a toutes les
options intérieures pour le confort des
passagers qu'on va venir retrouver ici
qui sera très très intuitif sans oublier
juste en dessous le drive select qui va
venir vous afficher sur votre écran duo
vos différents types de conduite ici on
est sur un chemin donc on se met en
Offroad ça va venir remonter le véhicule
dure le Road de l'efficience confort ou
alors carrément on se met en mode
automatique on est bien évidemment ici
sur une boîte automatique et je vous le
dis pour la petite info 0 à 100 en 5,6
secondes alors c'est pas ce que j'ai
essayé de plus rapide mais croyez moi
vous avez pas besoin de faire beaucoup
mieux on peut venir faire beaucoup mieux
sur d'autres véhicules mais celle-là
comme elle est là il ira très très bien
de toute façon pour une vitesse maximale
de 200 km/h tout en sachant que vous ne
pouvez pas le faire sur la route ça sera
sur circuit et plus vous allez appuyer
et plus vous allez rouler vite et plus
vous de sollicité et plus autonomie
descendra même si vous voyez ici Audi a
fait des efforts pour augmenter
l'autonomie du véhicule ainsi que la
charge rapide le dernier écran se trouve
ici à l'arrière pour les passagers ça
c'est quand même plutôt pratique vous
allez pouvoir venir régler certaines
choses alors c'est un écran sans
réellement être un écran c'est un écran
bien évidemment avec surtout un toucher
optique température vous réglez vous
réglez votre ventilation vous sentez
vraiment sous le doigt la petite ça
c'est vachement bien et puis après
quelques petites options bien évidemment
et là vous êtes vraiment l'affichage qui
se fait ici en fait les écrans c'est
plus ça là et derrière ça va être plutôt
je pense un rétroéclairage mais bon
c'est quand même un autre écran et ce
qui est pratique c'est qu'en plus si
vous regardez juste en dessous vous avez
deux prises USB C pour finir surcharger
vous avez également un petit 12 volts là
histoire de se marrer et vous allez
retrouver également à l'avant deux
prises USB C alors là on est venu mettre
des petits câbles Lightning et USB C
histoire de se marrer mais vous avez
deux usb-c ici pour venir vous recharger
très rapidement alors on peut venir
refermer cette petite partie là mais bon
on a mis quand même vachement de bazar
ici différents téléphones bref c'est
très pratique parce que c'est un vrai
petit range tout et vous avez également
ici du 12 Volts aussi si vous souhaitez
venir le brancher et vous avez
globalement plein de rangements ici tous
les côtés donc c'est vrai que cette
voiture d'un point de vue purement
habitacle à l'intérieur c'est hyper
confort c'est spacieux bien évidemment
les sur une voiture très haut de gamme
donc c'est complètement normal avec tout
ce qui conviendra pour de la
connectivité
[Musique]
il y a un autre point moi qui m'a un peu
interpellé c'est que des fois on
freinant j'avais l'impression que vous
voyez ça écrasait pas ça freinait pas
directement j'ai pris le temps d'en
parler un peu avec les chefs de produits
en disant en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi est-ce que la voiture elle m'a
pas freiné énormément il me dit parce
qu'en fait au début quand tu commences à
appuyer sur la c'est sur du
freinage régénératif donc c'est pas les
plaquettes que tu vas actionner c'est en
gros le frein moteur qui va permettre à
ta voiture de freiner on appuyant sur la
de frein clairement donc il y a
pas ce mordant directement et plus tu
vas appuyer fort et plus là tu vas
vraiment venir enclencher les plaquettes
tout en sachant qu'on est sur un
véhicule qui doit faire quelque chose
comme à peu près 2 tonnes de tonnes 5 je
vais pas vous dire de bêtises donc elle
est extrêmement lourde donc elle va
mettre plus de temps à s'arrêter donc il
y a vraiment cette combinaison entre les
deux entre d'un côté ce freinage
régénératif que vous avez au début et
les plaquettes qui vont arriver après et
cette voiture qui de toute façon reste
très lourde extrêmement lourde de par
toutes les cellules que vous avez à
l'intérieur ce qui fait que du coup on
se retrouve avec une voiture qui va pas
avoir autant de morts dans qu'on aurait
avec un véhicule qui sera beaucoup plus
léger ou avec un thermique plus léger
[Musique]
il y a un truc qu'il faut savoir ici
c'est qu'en fait cette voiture elle est
pas temps destinée au grand public elle
est pas tant destinée aux particuliers
alors bien évidemment si vous avez un
peu moins de 100000 balles voire un peu
plus avec les options et bien vous allez
pouvoir venir acheter ce véhicule mais
c'est pas cette typologie de clientèle
que s'adresse Audi en fait au 10
adresses réellement ici plus aux
entreprises aux professionnels ou B to
be au flotte de véhicule d'entreprise
plus pour des cadres dirigeants grand
patron de grandes entreprises qui ont
besoin de grosses bagnoles à plus de
100000 balles mais une fois de plus les
particuliers c'est pas lui qui va être
ciblé ici et au sujet qui est
intéressant et j'en parlais il y a pas
longtemps avec des collègues qui ont
justement cette problématique en
entreprise c'est que aujourd'hui et bien
en période de crise en période
d'inflation les entreprises vont faire
vachement plus attention là où je prends
l'exemple de cette voiture là avant une
entreprise aller prendre pour un cadre
dirigeant et bien un Q8 i Tron peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui ils vont aller plus vers
un Q5 pour essayer de rationaliser donc
bon je suis pas convaincu que Audi vende
énormément en volume en masse de Q8 mais
en fait ce qui est très important pour
une marque comme Audi ici en proposant
des voitures
extrêmement Premium et bien c'est pas
tant la quantité de volume qui va être
vendu c'est valoriser qui sont présents
sur le secteur ultra premium pour
réussir à vendre des voitures un peu
moins cher donc tout ce qui va être des
voitures ça va être une Audi A1 jusqu'à
de la A3 jusqu'à de la Q3 et bien c'est
vraiment là-dessus qui vont faire leur
beurre et c'est là-dessus qui vont venir
vendre énormément de véhicules et le
fait de sortir aujourd'hui une Q8 i Tron
et bien ça va servir à vendre ses
véhicules là qui sont moins chers pour
aller toujours plus dans le côté premium
notamment au niveau de l'électrique
c'est un peu comme les smartphones je
fais vraiment cette analogie là parce
que je vous parle énormément de
smartphone sur la chaîne vous prenez une
marque comme Xiaomi qui va vous
présenter des smartphones à plus de 1000
balles ou des smartphones qui se plie il
est évident que c'est pas ses
smartphones là qui vont vendre au plus
grand nombre mais par contre ça leur
servira avant d'autant plus et à
d'autant plus valoriser la qualité de la
marque sur les smartphones d'entrée et
milieu de gamme c'est vraiment là-dessus
le beurre se fait et c'est exactement la
même chose ici dans l'automobile après
il y a aussi un truc qui est vachement
intéressant à comprendre entre d'un côté
le marché allemand et le marché français
au dis ça vous aura pas échappé c'est
une marque allemande pour autant les
marques vont travailler différemment le
marché français le marché allemand grâce
à ce sont deux équipes différentes c'est
des équipes marketing où en Allemagne on
va venir privilégier d'abord la
motorisation c'est à dire que de base de
série vous avez un moteur surboosté
là-bas vous le savez les autoroutes vous
avez pas fatalement de limitation de
vitesse ça dépend des portions bien
évidemment et bien qu'est-ce qui se
passe et bien il y a une culture en
Allemagne où on veut un moteur on veut
de la puissance directement de série on
veut de la puissance et puis tout ce qui
va être équipement en plus on s'en fiche
un peu c'est plus secondaire donc ça
arrivera après et on le prendra plus en
option là où en France la question de la
puissance moteur et moins importante
elle est juste là si on n'est pas
exactement la même sur autoroute on est
plus limité et puis on est dans une
prise de conscience du fait qu'il faut
rouler moins vite faire attention il y a
eu beaucoup de campagne de prévention de
la sécurité routière là-dessus c'est
vraiment différent donc en France on va
travailler avec des moteurs moins
puissants dès le départ et puis ça va
être des options donc plus vous allez
vouloir de puissance plus vous allez
prendre d'option et c'est pareil pour
tout ce qui va être équipement à
l'intérieur donc on comprend qu'on a
vraiment une différence entre d'un côté
la mise en vente de produits sur le
marché allemand et de l'autre côté sur
le marché français alors après moi il y
a un truc qui fait un petit peu râler
c'est ce que je disais hier au chef
produit de audit c'est à dire que on se
retrouve avec une voiture qui coûte
96000 euros de base c'est à dire série
sans option et que si vous voulez des
options vous allez payer plus cher ce
que je comprends évidemment mais pour
moi il y a une option qui devrait pas
être une option c'est l'affichage tête
haute pour moi l'affichage tête haute ça
me paraîtrait tellement logique dans une
voiture surpris de l'avoir de série et
bien non l'affichage tête haute est une
option alors j'ai pas regardé les tarifs
je les avais détaillé mais j'ai pas
regardé donc voyez c'est des trucs ça me
fait un peu ah 4 ans la voiture quand
même après je comprends la logique de ce
dire il faut qu'on en rajoute petit à
petit pour gagner un peu plus d'argent
sauf que l'affichage tête haute pour moi
ça sera un truc quand même assez
important et si vous voyez mais bon on
l'a pas de série
[Musique]
alors verdict qu'est-ce que je pense de
cette voiture comment est-ce que je me
sens dans la piloter en mettant en
volant alors déjà le premier truc c'est
bien évidemment c'est spacieux c'est
agréable c'est grand on a de la place
bien évidemment on est dans le plus haut
de gamme de Audi aujourd'hui en terme
d'électrification donc on a un modèle
qui est extrêmement bien maîtrisé bien
évidemment ici ce que 8 est magnifique
ce conduit bien il y a du coup il y a de
la reprise ça marche bien ça ok ok ok ça
c'est la base on va pas chanter les
louanges du modèle mais il est bien
aucun problème là-dessus alors moi ce
que j'ai trouvé super intéressant il y a
ça impressionnant c'est que lorsqu'on
roulait sur des routes en travaux avec
des petites roues des bosses de tous les
côtés et bien il y avait un vrai confort
au niveau des suspensions j'avais
l'impression de rouler sur du coton
alors que j'avais des trous sous mes
pneus donc c'est vrai qu'il y a des
suspensions qui sont vraiment bien
maîtrisées c'est confortables c'est
agréable confort à l'intérieur et
vraiment là donc on sent pas du tout on
a fait aussi du Offroad en venant se
balader sur des chemins alors on a
tartiné la bagnole de poussière de tous
les côtés alors bien évidemment arrivé
au moment où on sent les bosses mais
c'est très amorti c'est très doux et
c'est très confort donc ça c'est
chouette alors moi le truc qui m'a un
peu perturbé et bien c'est ce système de
rétroviseur par des écrans à l'intérieur
alors autant je trouve ça intéressant je
trouve ça intelligent parce qu'en fait
ça évite d'emmener l'O beaucoup moins
loin qu'en allant sur un rétroviseur
extérieur je l'ai vraiment à l'intérieur
je trouve ça malin je trouve ça plutôt
cool après ce qui est assez
déstabilisant là-dedans c'est que moi ça
fait aller j'en sais rien ça va faire 25
ans que je conduis que j'ai le permis
donc j'ai l'habitude de regarder un peu
plus loin donc mon œil il va pas
directement dessus il y a un truc qui
est pas très naturel pour moi alors
c'est pas propre à ce véhicule il y a
d'autres véhicules qui ont ce système là
avec des caméras mais j'avais jamais
conduit j'avais jamais vu j'avais jamais
expérimenté je trouve ça pas mal mais je
pense qu'il faut quand même un certain
temps d'adaptation j'ai pas réussi à
adapter il faut dire que je la conduit
depuis ce matin donc fatalement ça va
pas très vite il y a des moments où ça
va bien il y a des moments où c'est un
peu plus dur mais l'idée d'avoir ce truc
un peu tactile je trouve ça marrant de
le piloter de l'intérieur de pas avoir
de rétroviseur qui risque de géoler
alors pour autant est-ce que votre
caméra risque de geler lorsqu'il fait
des températures négatives j'en sais
fichement rien tout de suite voilà
avantage inconvénient voyez c'est un
petit peu dur à venir maîtriser le truc
que j'aurais aimé que j'aimerais Audi
développe et qui font toujours pas
aujourd'hui c'est l'expérience logiciel
à l'intérieur alors je pense que tous
les détenteurs d'audit en tout cas sur
ces hauts de gamme probablement il y a
connais ce système là sur les véhicules
récents j'aimerais bien que ça aille un
peu plus loin au niveau de leur OS pour
avoir un truc un petit peu plus intuitif
c'est bien beau d'avoir des écrans de
tous les côtés effectivement on peut
venir personnaliser on peut aller loin
il faut le temps de rentrer un petit peu
dedans alors quand on le maîtrise ok
mais dès le départ vous voyez il manque
un truc qui est pas encore assez
intuitif et là où d'autres marques comme
Tesla notamment vont pouvoir aller
là-dessus ça je voulais déjà dit je le
rabâche mais bon une fois qu'on commence
un peu à le prendre en main on commence
à ne pas s'y faire je commence un peu à
prendre mes repères à comprendre pour
dire aller dans mes paramètres pour mes
phares matrix LED bon ok pourquoi pas
mais voyez il manque un truc un peu sexy
pour un novice qui arrive et qui connaît
pas tout nécessairement donc
l'expérience globale est belle le
véhicule est beau la puissance est là
audi va améliorer l'autonomie au divin
améliorer la performance audi va donner
un coup de neuf à son Q8 pour le rendre
encore plus actuel encore plus sexy pour
moi c'est réussi est-ce que pour autant
ça va venir convaincre pour un véhicule
qui coûte quasiment 100000 euros parce
que j'ai les tarifs et je vous les donne
c'est quand même un véhicule extrêmement
cher on est dans le haut de gamme du
premium ici chez Audi si vous allez sur
la version
Q8 S line 55i tronquattro et bien on
commence à partir de 96200 euros et si
vous allez sur la version Sportback
toujours en 55 il trône quattro 98200 et
ça c'est sans parler des options où vous
allez remonter à des tarifs 120.130000
euros ça va dépendre bien évidemment on
est dans les voitures extrêmement
premium dans du luxe c'est pas fait pour
tout le monde ça coûte un bras de bras
tous les bras de vos potes mais pour
autant pour ceux qui ont les moyens qui
veulent se faire plaisir et qui aiment
la marque Audi pourquoi pas
l'électrification est réussie moi je
trouve ça plutôt intéressant d'ailleurs
vous je sais pas est-ce que vous avez
une Audi est-ce que vous êtes plutôt IP
par toutes ces technologies qu'on vient
retrouver dans cette Q8 i Tron de 2023
de 2022 mais là on est en 2023 est-ce
que ça vous plaît est-ce que c'est
quelque chose qui pourrait vraiment vous
tenter d'ailleurs dites moi tout ça en
bas dans les commentaires puis nous on
va continuer à parler d'automobile on en
parle par-ci par là parce que les
technologies parce que j'aime la techno
et quand on voit des merveilles
technologiques comme cette voiture est
bien on vient en parler donc vous dites
moi ce que vous en pensez donnez-moi
votre avis est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
parle davantage de voiture si oui sous
quel axe bien évidemment vous marquez
tout ça en bas dans les commentaires et
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler de take on peut
l'automobile beaucoup de smartphones
beaucoup d'objets connectés et surtout
de vous et de votre rapport à la
technologie voilà je trouve ça cool je
vous embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
très bientôt et gros bisous du Portugal
[Musique]